[Music]
britney spears is living her best life
naked on a tropical island with her man
yeah it's cool on thursday the 39 year
old pop star shared several snaps from
her getaway with beyonce sam
on instagram that's britt topless on the
beach rocking some red bikini bottoms
and that's the toxic singer totally
naked by the tub with a few
strategically placed emojis
it's fun for me she captioned the post
quote playing in the pacific never hurt
anybody
and she had a message for all the haters
who might point to the waves in the tub
and claim she photoshopped the images
quote no photo edits the tub curves
baby we bought you ireland we're pulling
up right now oh you shouldn't have
britt also shared that sweet clip
writing having the time of my life here
and if all that weren't enough the
singer also shared a video montage of
the whole getaway we're talking boat
rides secluded beaches and seductive
topless walks towards the camera people
[Music]
the caption a beautiful day here in
paradise celebrating it's really kind of
exciting while brit and sam might be
celebrating their recent engagement they
could also be celebrating the recent
ruling in brittany's conservatorship
case on wednesday the judge suspended
her dad jamie spears as the conservator
of her estate
[Applause]
e.t was at the l.a courthouse when the
ruling came down and while jaime's
official removal will be decided at a
later date the pop star's attorney told
et on wednesday that she's happy about
the judge's most recent ruling and the
future is bright where do you see
brittany's life going from here as she
talked about what she might want to do
when this is over in a month if
hopefully she's got a great future ahead
of her and shortly after the hearing
brittany posted this video from the
cockpit of a plane to instagram
alongside the caption quote on cloud
nine right now
britney spears has been faced
with a decade-long nightmare
orchestrated by her father
and others and i'm so proud of her
for her courage
her strength and her poignancy and she's
so thankful to all of you
[Music]
you